yes a lot of requests from you guys for
me to review Metal Gear Solid 5 the
phantom pain I'm a huge Metal Gear Solid
fancy you knew it was coming but with my
Metal Gear Solid games I like sipping
them slowly like a fine wine draw a
bubble bath just enjoy the moment and
100 gameplay hours later not even lying
to you 100 game flowers in this game
finally beat it here's the review
Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain so
Metal Gear Solid 5 is actually it's the
sixth Metal Gear Solid game if you're
counting piece Walker which you should
get as a kijima game also and this is
the last Metal Gear Solid game to be
brought to us by creator Hideo Kojima
not his fault Konami fired him because
the evil empire so this is essentially a
send-off of sorts it's an end of an era
so how does the final game stack up
pretty friggin sweet this game takes
place nine years after the events of
ground zeroes which is the precursor to
this game big bosses in Tacoma because
his huge accident here's a big thing
sticking out of his head he's scarred up
in the face and you have to rebuild
mother base because it was burned down
essentially it just takes the piece
Walker and it's like alright let's wreck
the base you built and you have to do
all that again
I feel like this game just scrapped
spacewalker although there are things
that tie into this game so Peace Walker
still relevant gameplay wise though this
is everything I liked about Peace Walker
but done better and it is an open world
unlike Peace Walker which when you're on
a mission you only have that section of
mission zone this has a section of
mission zone but you can just free roam
the world and it's enormous and it
actually works against you because I'm
so used to Medicare sellers they aren't
the guys you see those are the guys you
got to take out I'm just doing this
mission I'm taking guys out and I guess
way over there guys were walking this
direction twenty minutes into this
mission they finally got to me and
they're like hey who are you what are
you doing contact Bri and then I got
seen you still gotta watch your back
because just because someone's not on
the map doesn't mean they're not going
to be on the map liking Peace Walker you
go out there you can stun soldiers out
there on the battlefield use the Fulton
system send them back to mother base now
they work for you better you are at
stealth the more your legend grows and
more people like I just want to sign up
anyone you get your R&D department up
you can make new weapons new gears is
really customizable game you feel like
you are building something special in
something great in this game and I love
that I was like stun sniper rifle pistol
and the doc did you get buddies the dog
is the best cuz the dog can sniff out
guys and you know where everyone is
you're like sweet all I got to do is
just take him out now
I mean quiet was a great character but
did the dog and you start seeing gear
that you can create later on you're like
I see the sniper rifle with the silencer
that stuns guys I wanted all right let's
get R&D and medical up let's get to work
you really concentrate on the side ops
which actually kind of works against the
game story because the story is in the
main ops starring some side ops that are
also important but ultimately the main
ops is going
have the meat of the story but a lot of
its told through audio cassette tapes
that you get post-mission just like a
debriefing that Kaz Miller does with you
there are cutscenes in this game but not
as much as there have been in the Metal
Gear Solid franchise and I actually
didn't like that as much as I like
cutscenes I know there are a lot of
gamers out there like I hate the
45-minute cutscenes get rid of him so he
did in this game he told the story
through different means I guess I'm just
an old-school metal gear solid fan I'm
like give me the 45 minute cutscene if
I'm playing a movie awesome the gameplay
is still there it's not taking away from
that I just get a really sweet cinematic
movie along with it and another Metal
Gear Solid games you know a lot of the
story was told through codex also so
it's not new in this game I just wanted
more cutscenes I feel like big boss in
this game didn't say as much as he did
in peace Walker and Snake Eater but
here's how it went down for me you play
some main ops you get some story they're
like alright I need to build my R&D
department which means I need to farm
guys which means I need to recruit them
which means I need to do side up so you
do a lot of side apps you're like not
they're not there yet I need better gear
not that you do hours upon hours of side
ops and you finally get to make the gear
that you wanted to make and you go back
to the main store and you're like
alright let's pick this thing up what
was I doing again where's this story
right now here's a little perspective if
you go out there and play a few hours of
side ops that's like doing one main
story and then putting this game down
entirely playing the entirety of the
first Metal Gear Solid game because
that's how many hours are in that game
and after beating Metal Gear Solid 1 you
come back to Metal Gear Solid 5 phantom
pain sure so that's how many hours are
in between main story revelations
because you're doing side ops not
complaining because the gameplay is
[ __ ] fantastic kind of detracts from
the main story it doesn't feel like the
story flows now after you beat this game
if you go back and do all the main ops
and you can see the cutscenes in between
and do the side ops that are relevant to
the story it probably flows very well in
you're like oh yeah that's the Metal
Gear Solid synergy I was looking for
that and I didn't care about skull face
and what he was I just didn't care about
him there is an interesting ideology
really dark ideology behind what he's
doing in his motivation and in true
kijima fashion he does give you data to
support the motivation you're like [ __ ]
that might work would that work and
there kind of twists your mind a little
bit and you love saying that but
ultimately think of this game is being
divided into two games the first half of
this game not as enjoyable as the second
half the second half got into the meat
of what I wanted to see in this game
that's where the impactful scenes were
that's where the feels were all in the
second half of this game and that's what
Hideo Kojima has always
that's what he has given us in this
Metal Gear Solid game as the Metal Gear
swan song great gameplay a solid
universe everything in this game is
bigger but in a better way some games
try to be bigger but it's not better
just thinking about the other Metal Gear
Solid games which I might personally
prefer in the sense of nostalgia because
nostalgia is impossible to defeat you
can't beat a nostalgic you take pac-man
someone's like pac-man is the greatest
game ever I can tell you it's not but if
you have that nostalgic tie in your
childhood - pac-man - you pac-man's the
best thing ever
that's how Metal Gear Solid 1 is for me
or Snake Eater I just love those games
but in terms of scope and gameplay those
games are so isolated and so small
everyone you take on is in a room and
it's just as closed off a little room
phantom pain it's a world man and it's
huge and you can explore it I haven't
even touched on a topographical
structure of this world holy [ __ ] I was
walking around and does nothing is
irrelevant you know those games will
take Mass Effect 1 for example you do
different missions in Mass Effect 1 and
you go into these buildings but
ultimately you notice that every
building is the same mission as the last
building just some doors might not open
but ultimately it's the same map you're
like okay same map I get what it is this
[ __ ]
is so different all the cliffs and the
fields and the valleys and the roads and
the weather and the mountains is all
constructed so beautiful and you're like
it's a living environment that [ __ ] they
must have been working on this game for
the past 10 years guys I'm going to
break it down for you like this Metal
Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain is sad
that there aren't as many cinematics in
this game as other Metal Gear Solid
games have had I liked the cinematics I
prefer the cinematics but you do still
get this story you do still get the
conflict you get the strife I love big
boss and his crew big boss Ocelot and
Miller they're not all on the same page
on things the main runners of motherbase
have different perspectives on how
things should be handled and it does
cause some conflict among the ranks in
here this has the best Metal Gear Solid
gameplay i have played yet and i have
played and lived them all open worlds
beautiful i have not seen an open-world
game use the open world in a better way
than Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain
does among the flawless game played the
villains skull face I really didn't care
for him at all I loved Eli although
there is no resolution in his story and
then you find out that that chapter was
actually cut from the game and you can't
help but just blame Konami for that [ __ ]
seriously the last
after of this game is going to be
resolution with a line in the end it's
just not there this game has the moments
it has the feels it has the Shockers I
loved all 100-plus gameplay hours I put
into this game and after this review I'm
still going to go back and do more [ __ ]
because it's just it's fun to do and a
game that can keep you coming back after
you've beaten the game that's the game
worth having I will say Metal Gear Solid
5 the phantom pain is the send-off that
Hideo Kojima deserves and it is awesome
tacular now I will say this there is
something in this game we'll call it the
end it's very divisive among fans and
it's worth doing its own video I'm not
going to mention it in here but I have
my thoughts on it and so I will do that
video next luring a Star Wars trailer
dropping out of the sky tomorrow it's
gonna be the next video I do and if
you're wondering what I thought about
the other Metal Gear Solid games in the
Metal Gear Solid franchise I put links
in the description you can check them
all out
lots of Metal Gear Solid to go around or
some Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain
have you played it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more